Поки у Москві проводять репетицію щорічного параду до Дня перемоги, на Заході сперечаються про те,
що готує Путін для України, Заходу та своїх громадян на честь 9 травня.
Чи оголосять у Кремлі цього дня перемогу чи початок повномасштабної війни проти України?
У Німеччині побоюються другого варіанта.
Як наголосив в інтерв'ю газеті Augsburger Allgemeine експерт ХДС із зовнішньої політики Родеріх Кізеветтер,
варто побоюватися, що Володимир Путін оголосить загальну мобілізацію 9 травня.
Тоді в Росії буде введено воєнний стан, і на військову службу зможуть призвати до 900 000 людей з резерву.
Якщо це станеться, то це призведе до жахливої ​​ескалації війни.
Схожі застереження звучать і з Великобританії, від міністра оборони Бена Воллеса.
А у держдепартаменті США кажуть, що такі плани Кремля можуть свідчити про визнання невдач на полі бою.
Це було б великою іронією, якби Москва скористалася нагодою Дня перемоги для оголошення війни.
Це дозволило б їм збільшити призов до армії, чого вони не можуть зробити зараз.
І це було б рівносильно заяві цілому світу, що військові зусилля РФ зазнають невдачі,
а російська військова кампанія та досягнення військових цілей буксують.
Чутки про загальну мобілізацію в Росії з'явилися ще на початку війни. Тоді вони не підтвердилися.
Прессекретар Кремля Пєсков спростував їх і цього разу. Але навіть якщо мобілізацію буде оголошено, на її проведення потрібен час.
Цю мобілізацію спершу потрібно буде провести, тобто підписати відповідні укази, потім мобілізувати промисловість,
призвати призовників, призвати резервістів, створити резервні частини, які досі не використовувалися.
А це означає, що, ймовірно, знадобиться кілька місяців.
Поки що в Україні воюють вихідці з глибокої провінції, столичних жителів так звана "спецоперація" безпосередньо не зачіпає.
Але все може змінитися, якщо російська влада наважиться на загальну мобілізацію.
Ми всі рахувалися з тим, що 9 травня 2022 року відбудеться рімейк параду перемоги 1945 року.
Але є інший варіант - рімейк параду листопада 1941 року. Коли війська прямо з Червоної площі пішли на фронт.
Сказати, що за нами - Невський і Жуков. Це теж варіант.
Я вважаю за можливе оголошення загальної мобілізації. Путін сам себе загнав як щура у кут. І у нього нема гарного виходу з цієї війни.
Розуміючи, що з цією армією неможливо здобути перемогу, Путін може піти на відчайдушний крок, який занапастить його насамперед, але й багатьох інших.
Це загальна мобілізація приблизно 500-600 тисяч людей до 40 років.
Це буде масштабна війна з величезною кількістю жертв - насамперед для Росії, але й для України.
У своєму божевіллі вони можуть піти на такий крок. Це продовження логіки божевілля, що охопило Кремль.
Критики Кремля вважають, що зростання кількості похоронок, до якого призведе можлива мобілізація, російське суспільство проковтне.
І масштабних акцій протесту з цього приводу не варто очікувати.
Соціологічні дослідження показують, що війну найменше підтримують якраз молоді люди. Це саме ті, яких можуть призвати в армію.
Грубо кажучи, роздадуть на 600 тисяч людей зброю, а вони війну не підтримають.
Вони або пачками здаватися почнуть, або повернуть цю зброю проти режиму. Я думаю, що в Кремлі це теж розуміють.
Західні експерти також сумніваються, що Путін захоче брати на себе внутрішньополітичні ризики такого рішення.
Великою проблемою також є відсутність у багатьох солдатів мотивації воювати.
Адже за логікою влади захоплення України мало б стати такою метою, за яку люди тепер справді були б готові віддати свої життя.
Якщо ви залучаєте широкі верстви суспільства у війну, відправляючи їх на фронт у ролі солдатів і даючи їм там загинути, це, звичайно, матиме наслідки.
Існує ймовірність того, що серед населення посилиться опір режиму та самому Путіну.
Наступ на Донбасі триває, і до 9 травня жодних серйозних успіхів не передбачається.
Проте Путін все одно зможе піднести своєму народу так звану "спецоперацію" як "перемогу".
Якби треба було оголосити перемогу сьогодні, можна було б говорити про значний контроль над Маріуполем і про коридор на півдні,
а також про те, яких збитків російські війська завдали українським збройним силам.
Це, звичайно ж, пропагандистський наратив, тому що в цьому випадку власні втрати втрати всіляко применшуються.
У Маріуполі, наприклад, була захоплена база "Азова", були захоплені машини, які, звичайно, можна було б прокотити Червоною площею
і подати, так би мовити, з розмахом, незалежно від того, продовжуються в Маріуполі бойові дії чи ні.
Абсолютно неважливо, що відбувається на Донбасі - важливо, що показують по телевізору.
Ще одна версія розвитку подій в Україні - анексія Донецька, Луганська та Херсона.
Про це повідомляє газета Washington Post із посиланням на американську розвідку. Чи може це статися 9 травня?
9 травня можуть озвучити запрошення Донецьку і Луганську приєднатися до Російської Федерації.
Але щоб це сталося, у цих двох сепаратистських регіонах, звичайно, має бути проведений референдум.
Він не буде демократичним, але має бути хоч якась легітимність приєднання цих так званих народних республік до Росії.
Це неможливо зробити до 9 травня, але запросити їх приєднатися до Російської Федерації, безумовно, можливо.
І це теж можна було б продати як свого роду успіх.
А ось те, що 9 травня буде оголошено кінець війні в Україні, експерти, з якими поспілкувалася DW,
вважають вкрай оптимістичним та практично неможливим сценарієм.